عندما تقرر خساره بعض الوزن مباشره تفكر
في حساب كميات الطعام وممارسه الرياضه
ولمن ياخذ الموضوع بجديه اكبر بالتاكيد
سيحسب السعرات الحراريه في الطعام لكن
فريقا جديدا من الخبراء يرى ان حساب
السعرات وسيله غير مجديه وقد تكون ضاره
احيانا خاصه اذا تحولت لعوز يزيد من العبء
النفسي على الفرد اختصاصيون والتغذيه
الرافدين لحساب السعرات الحراريه يؤكدون
ان هذه العمليه لا تعتمد فقط على نوعيه
الطعام بل تتاثر بعدد الكبير من المتغيرات
الفرديه مثل العمر والحركه والى ما لا
نهايه من التعقيدات التي تصل الى عدد
البكتيريا الموجوده في الامعاء فهل فعلا
حساباتنا خاطئه كل هذه السنين ونحن ودقيق
في ملصقات الاغذيه والسعرات الحراريه التي
تحتوي
بدايه خلينا نعرف شو يعني سعره حراريه الا
السعرات هي الطاقه اللي بتكون موجوده
بالقطع الاطعمه المتناوله وهذه الطاقه لما
تكون تفوق احتياجات الجسم وقتيها راح يتم
تخزينها الى داخل الدهون والمعادله اللي
بتقول انه اذا احنا قلنا من تناول السعرات
الحراريه فوقتيها الجسم راح يلجا للدهون
المخزنه كمصدر للطاقه تعويضا لا النقص
اللي صار وهي معادله صحيحه 100% ولكن
الاعتماد على فكره فقط الاحتساب سعرات
الحراريه الداخلي والخارجه لوحده غير كافي
لعمليه انقاص الوزن لانه هناك عوامل اخرى
بتدخل او بتاثر بعمليه التمثيل الغذائي
وايضا معدلات الحرق بالجسم ومن اهم هذه
العوامل هي الجينات العوامل الوراثيه
العوامل الجينيه وكمان نوعيه الاطعمه لها
دور الاكبر بالتحكم او بخساره الوزن همم
ممكن انا اتناول سعره حراريه من همم قطعه
من البسكويت او اللوحه شوكلت وايضا ممكن
اتناول نفس القدر من السعرات الحراريه من
حبه فاكهه ولكن تاثير همم السعرات على
الجسم بتكون مختلفه لانه لما انا اخذ معظم
السعرات الحراريه من السكريات العاليه راح
تؤدي الى اثار على الصحه منها مقاومه
الانسولين اللي بتادي الى صعوبه بنزول
الوزن